i feel like we have a lot of growth uh
that happened
um over the past year and
i titled the good news because yes we've
been having an extremely crazy year and
what felt like we were getting bad news
back to back like i thought
making a stallion used to drop some good
news okay
so many things that you've accomplished
this year and now we're adding fashion
designer to
the resume um so excited for you what
can you tell us about
your job and what you wanted to make i'm
so excited for
my fashion nova launch because we're
finally getting jeans for the long leg
girls okay
like fashion nova jeans have always
hugged my booty real good
real tight fit great great stretch
but they always look like capris
so i'm like look fashion nova i don't
know what y'all gonna do
but baby we need some jeans for girls
that's five eight plus
everybody bite size so i'm super excited
for that the tall girls are finally
getting representation
um but it's not just about tall girls
like i have petite
um slim curvy whatever you are we got
the jeans beard
i love this so much and i love that i i
think that people might not realize
that you're 5 10 i mean you're super
model height
i have long legs i have long arms so
that is another thing in my collection
too
i have the shirts with the extended
sleeves as well like
we have the outfits that cater to
everybody in this collection
this is the primary benefit of becoming
a global superstar is you can just start
making clothes for yourself
at this point but i know it's not just
me like i'm like
i wasn't the only person born 510 with a
big butt
so i'm like girl i got y'all i got us i
see us
and did you learn anything during this
fashion nova
collab that you would take into like
your own namesake line like or is that
even on the table yet
no that's definitely on the table like i
just realized
how how big of a
lack and representation there is for
curvier girls or taller girls or girls
with bigger feet
like everybody is not just a cookie
cutter
size so i just want to make sure that
starting with this collab
we have better representation and with
just women in general like even short
girls
the jeans are made for skinny short
girls like it's just it's not just about
the model body it's about the real body
so this this collection definitely
caters to
women with curves being a curvy woman
especially a curvy woman of color i have
always found it a little difficult to go
into like
a more designer store and find something
that fits
to my body even when i became making a
stallion i would go to some of these
photo shoots
and they would not have clothes that fit
me and i'll be like i know i told you
all my size like i know my team had to
have talked to y'all
and y'all should know what fits me like
it made me want to be like
where are the designers that are going
to cater to somebody that looks like me
so if i can put my hand in the health
and pot
and help everybody that i know has had a
struggle like me then that's what i
wanted to do
half the time i'll look around and be
like damn
really doing this like like i'm really a
part of this this is so crazy to me
and it's me just being my genuine self
and people being receptive to it and i
just super appreciate
everybody today that gives gives me
platforms to speak on
and allows me to be myself and be megan
because
at the end of the day i don't know who
else i would even be in such a bad year
this has been such a big year for
your career what does it feel like to be
putting out this album
the debut meghan the stallion album
like if you know me and you kept up with
the things i've said
i was always super scared to drop a
project
titled an album because i'm like oh my
god that's such a commitment that's like
a husband
and i just want to date and have fun
these are mix tapes these are projects
eps
like it just felt like marriage actually
saying this is an album
so for me to actually get committed
and call and call something album i feel
very mature
i feel like we have a lot of growth that
happened
um over the past year and
i titled the good news because yes we've
been having an extremely crazy year and
what felt like we were getting bad news
back-to-back like i thought
making a stallion needs to drop some
good news so that's why
i was excited like i said before this
year was filled with the two biggest
songs of the year you are
uh they're both your songs the savage
remix and
and and and walk with cardi um what's it
like to work with those two ladies and
how are they the same and how are they
different
like working with cardi and beyonce
it was just it was two totally different
experiences but they were both
like beyonce beyonce is the og like she
is the standard like you want to
be like beyonce you want to grow up you
want to be like beyonce you watch
beyonce from when you were a kid to this
point in life like beyonce is somebody
that is just so top tier so you just
feel so great to know that you've even
made it to where you can be in the room
with beyonce
like i'm like girls breathing beyonce
like
like that is a flex after savage remix
like i've said it before me and beyonce
and jay like have a very good
relationship they both text me all the
time and
they send me inspirational things and
like that is just so crazy
and cardi cardi is like my home girl
like she is so great she's so fun like
we both are very unapologetically us and
to to be two women with big
personalities and big confidence and
still be able to coexist comfortably
with
each other like that is like a really
big deal to me like i really respect her
i appreciate her um she's great like we
crack the same jokes
like she she's really somebody that i i
really appreciate having in my life
because she's great
stoking that fire of you won three bet
awards
uh you're up for five american music
awards um including new artist of the
year
what's your reaction to those
nominations and the wins
i'm always surprised and i'm always
excited and happy i remember when i went
to the amas
last year and i was just i was
presenting
and i was like oh my god like this is
just so epic in this room like everybody
was in there and i'm like oh my god i
can't even believe i'm in here
so this year to be performing i'm like
oh my god i can't believe i'm performing
at the amas like this is such
a big jump for me and i just always want
to impress my hobbies like i always want
them to feel like
they went on the journey with me and
they did go on they are going on the
journey with me so i'm just so excited
to
to be in the spot that i am now because
for everybody who's been watching me
until this point like you know you know
how hard i work and you know how
passionate i am about
music and just the fact that we made it
this far
like we need to pat all ourselves on the
back so in addition to the american
music award nominations at the end of
november we also get the grammy
nominations and you are a front-runner
what would it mean to you
to hear your name on the morning of the
nominations for the grammys
like i would be genuinely
excited like i would be probably jumping
out of my body you would not be able to
stop hearing my mouth
all that day uh now i don't make
my music in hopes of
getting awards and topping charts and
beating other people like things like
that don't matter to me i make music
that i really like
that i really enjoy and that i know that
my hobbies are going to enjoy
but to get the recognition from
you know award shows like this is a
really big
deep deal to me um because it's like
well that's that's kind of what you work
towards
but i'm really more so working towards
making my fans happy and making them
excited but this
this will really just be the icing on
the cake for me like i'll take it to my
grandma's house and be like
look baby we did it and
even though you were saying you were
working this whole time there was music
being made there was
the clothes were being made it has been
the pandemic has been a bummer
year and so how have you been have you
been coping with kind of
having to be inside and and those things
well when when quarantine first started
i was really
really truly scared like i was like oh
my god is
what what is covet like this is a
this is a really big deal like people
who i knew were getting sick and
their grandmothers and things were dying
and i couldn't go home and see my
grandmother because i didn't want to
risk her getting sick um
but i tried to figure out what what
makes me really happy
because when we were out in the world
where everybody was in each other's
faces every day
we can go do simple things like sit at a
restaurant we can go to the movies we're
going to the club like it was easy to go
outside
and hang out with other people and you
don't even realize
what you're genuinely thinking to
yourself because you've been with
everybody else for so long
so during quarantine like i feel like i
really got to
re-know myself i had to re-figure out
what makes me happy as an individual
i had to just really get into megan and
i really did that
and i was in the mirror the whole time
you were also you were also studying i
hope because
of your college degree i mean
the amount of things that you've taken
on and put on your shoulders and then
you're like i'll also go to college so
how is that going and then tell us about
these scholarships i know you're picking
a winner for the scholarships right now
this is incredible
school is so hard um and online classes
are really hard too but i was already
doing online classes before
quarantine started like i had to because
i couldn't go on campus anymore
but um i mean my focus was definitely
better because i didn't have
a lot of distractions but i'm still
in school and i'm projected to graduate
2021.
it's gonna be amazing when you sing and
you give the commencement speech as the
celebrity and you graduate
all at the same time we this is about to
be
i hope listen i hope they open outside
back up
and this we can put covet in the past
and treat it like a memory
because i want to have the most epic
graduation party like
i finally graduated we have to celebrate
the world has to be a part of our
celebration
i mean you're a global superstar you can
you're going to be successful for the
rest of your life
why is it so important for you to get a
college degree
i really have to start everything i have
to finish everything i start
i'm not a quitter and it's something
that i'm
what i'm studying is something that i'm
genuinely passionate about
my grandmother was a teacher she
definitely always pushes me to finish
school
when my mother was still alive she
definitely was pushing me to finish
college so
i'm definitely going to do it for those
two but i want to open up
the assisted living facilities like i
said and i just have to see this through
because i really want to see myself
accomplish that very commendable you are
an incredible woman
and i know the the lyrics and the buzz
and everything people are like oh my god
but look at this you know you know you
can be all things
yeah all things i love that
i don't want people to think that you
can't chase your dream and get your work
done
like if you are passionate about
something
if you're passionate about two things
just put your all into it because you
can complete it
and that's just my motto
you